bic c'est bon
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actualité à l'assemblée
et au sénat est aujourd'hui notre invité
avec kathia gilder pour commenter tous
les événements de la semaine passée le
député olivier falorni bonjour bonjour
et c'est katia qui va brosser votre
portrait bonjour olivier falorni merci
d'être sur notre plateau vous êtes
député de charente-maritime membres du
groupe liberté et territoires alors vous
siéger à l'assemblée depuis près d'une
décennie depuis votre première élection
en 2012 à l'époque vous refuser de céder
la candidature à ségolène royal ce qui
vous vaut d'être exclu du parti
socialiste mais vous gagnez contre l'ex
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
vous êtes un homme de conviction vous
portez à l'assemblée des sujets de
société majeur vous avez défendu la
cause animale
vous allez porter une proposition de loi
sur les abattoirs et vous militez depuis
très longtemps pour une aide active à
mourir de façon libre et choisit en
france on va y revenir longuement tout
de suite on va revenir sur le débat qui
vient d'avoir lieu mais peut-être une
question personnelle pour commencer à un
ordre la présidentielle vous olivier
falorni vous vous situez comment vous
sentez comment d'un rapport à la
majorité parlementaire
c'est vraiment j'ai fait le choix d'être
un député libre effectivement vous avez
évoqué mon élection de 2012
en 2017 j'ai eue contre moi candidat de
la république en marche l'investiture
m'avait été proposé
il devrait par part en marche et j'avais
fait le choix j'ai voté manuel macron
parce que toute façon il n'y avait pas
le choix et que je pensais que emmanuel
macron devait apporter ce souffle nous
aujourd'hui je reste libre août et 7
grand flou aujourd'hui sur sur
l'élection présidentielle je n'ai pas
évidemment déterminé ma position parce
que je m'y connais pas les candidats en
lice il va de soi évidemment que je
ferai en sorte que l'extrême droite ne
soit pas élu dans ce pays c'est ce que
je souhaite en tout cas elle est tout de
suite on va revient sur l'actualité de
la semaine et olivier falorni
l'assemblée a donc débattu de votre
proposition de loi pour le droit à une
fin de vie libre et choisit elle n'a pas
abouti plus de trois mille amendements
ont été déposés sur le tête malgré une
alliance transpartisane pour changer la
loi et le vote du premier article de
cette proposition de loi les sénateurs
poursuivent l'examen du projet de loi
séparatisme durci par la majorité de
droite
cette semaine ils ont interdit les
prières à l'université ou encore beauté
la suspension des allocations familiales
pour absentéisme scolaire
et puis on évoquera les élections
régionales et départementales le premier
ministre l'a promis elles auront lieu
sauf motif impérieux un débat est
organisé mardi prochain à l'assemblée et
mercredi au sénat et on commence cette
émission en revenant sur cette soirée
houleuse jeudi autour de votre
proposition de loi olivier falorni votre
texte pour une fin de vie libre est
choisi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui le texte crée un droit à une aide
active à mourir pour les personnes qui
souffrent notamment d'une maladie
incurable ou jugées insupportables
plus de trois mille amendements ont été
déposés sur ce texte qui a donné lieu à
un débat inachevé les divisions ont
dépassé les clivages politiques sur un
sujet qui reste sensible en france
compte rendu de séance l amont d'un gars
va quelques minutes avant minuit
le scrutin est ouvert les députés
adoptent l'article 1er de la proposition
de loi pour 240 contre 48
cet article 1
qui crée en france l'assistance
médicalisée active à mourir mais
impossible de continuer l'examen du
texte dans le temps imparti
plus tôt dans l'après midi s'est
accompagnée des milliers d'amendements
déposés sur son texte qu'olivier falorni
s'exprime à la tribune ses quatre mille
amendements mes chers collègues
ses feuilles elles n'ont qu'un but n ont
qu à but d'empêcher l'assemblée
nationale d'empêcher les représentants
de la nation d'empêcher les députés
peuvent voter vraiment à l'origine de
l'immense majorité de ces amendements a
pas cinq députés les républicains
farouchement opposés au texte
on constate trois semaines à la loi
pompili sur le climat on a consacré deux
heures aux voitures de collection 2/2 au
moulin moi je veux bien tout ce qu'on
veut mais la mort ce exige plus de
réflexion plus de temps plus de travail
si les débats parfois électrique ont mis
en avant un large accord trans partisan
sur ce texte
ils ont aussi fait apparaître des
clivages qui traversent les groupes
politiques
le gouvernement par la voix de son
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand a
fait part de ses réserves
à l'heure où notre pays est engagé dans
une course contre la montre pour
vacciner les français et vaincre un
virus qui a déjà fait tant de victimes
je ne suis pas c'est mon avis personnel
je n'impose à personne convaincu qu'il
nous faille ouvrir aujourd'hui ce débat
de cette envergure
faute de temps la proposition de loi n'a
pas abouti ses défenseurs pl est à
présent pour qu'elle soit inscrite à
l'ordre du jour par la majorité
alors olivier falorni l'examen du texte
n'a pas pu aller à son terme en raison
du nombre d'amendements déposés mais
l'article 1er qui crée cette assistance
médicale active à mourir a été votée
assez largement
est ce que vous voyez dans ce débat il
achevait un échec on compterait une
première victoire
et qu'est-ce qui va pas se passer
maintenant alors c'est un débat qui
n'est pas inachevé parce que ce texte il
est suspendu momentanément il peut
poursuivre son parcours et je souhaite
qu'il poursuive son parcours
effectivement réglementairement il s'est
arrêté à minuit nous avons pu malgré
l'obstruction massive de ces cinq
députés et l'eire qui voulaient nous
empêcher de voter sur l'article sur
l'article de 21h à 23h 50
eh bien nous avons eu 95 sous-amendement
et ils ont parlé à cinq ou six sans
arrêt sans arrêt sans arrêt pour nous
empêcher la cote ayant été voté de
l'article a été voté
le débat a été interrompue à minuit mais
le texte peut suivre son cours et c'est
ce que je souhaite moi j'en appelle au
gouvernement j'en appelle à la majorité
pour que nous puissions niche dans leur
nid chez eux ou à vent avant une niche à
vous qui a interviendront un certain
temps c'est cela que je crois que vous
avez mesuré otla évidemment de des
débats des différences de conviction
cette large très large majorité qui
s'est exprimée transpartisane vous dites
ans partie des invités de tout tous
bords politiques y compris dans la
majorité
absolument d'ailleurs vous avez a eu ce
spectacle je pense que vous ne verrez
pas de sitôt d'une insoumise acclamé par
les marchés risquent effectivement juste
pour revenir et bien sûr la position des
députés et l'eire qui ont déposé à eux
seuls alors qu'ils étaient cinq plus de
trois mille amendements les leur
répondre que c'est une liberté de
conscience on a aussi entendu des
arguments où ils disent on peut pas
consacrer aussi peu de temps pour
légiférer sur la mort est ce que ça vous
l'entendez non mais vous mesurez le
paradoxe de nous dire on n'a pas le
temps de délibérer et de prendre trois
heures de 21h à minuit de parler sans
arrêt de répéter la même chose
je vais peut-être faire un bêtisier
aussi des amendements qui ont été
déposés parce qu'en fait ils ont utilisé
le dictionnaire des synonymes
donc tout cela était navrant il faut
changer les règles pour empêcher cela
oui oui oui cette destruction c'est une
faillite démocratique
moi je suis évidemment attaché comme
tout parlementaire au droit à
l'amendement vous savez en commission
des affaires sociales la semaine
précédente
on a vu sept heures de débat les
collègues qui étaient contre avaient
déposé des amendements de suppression ce
qui est logique on avait débattu sur des
amendements d'enrichissement du texte et
des amendements de suppression
un débat de grande qualité qui avait
fait honneur à l'assemblée nationale on
aurait pu on aurait pu durant cette
journée parlementaire avoir la même
qualité de départ alors pour vous
donc ça le texte a été adopté en
commission il ne l'a pas été en séance
pour vous qui est responsable de cette
obstruction
est ce que ces cinq députés à l'avant
vous parlez aussi peut-être la majorité
qui peut-être a peur d'avancer sur ce
sujet alors je le redis ça n'est pas que
ce texte n'a pas été adopté
il a été suspendu voilà il n'a pas
poursuivi son parcours salue cependant
il est suspendu et vous avez bien
mesurer à travers le vote de l'article 1
que ce texte est largement soutenue donc
ça veut dire qu'il y aura une suite est
ce que ça peut être lors de la journée
réservée aux députés lrm de la majorité
qui souhaitent eux aussi majoritairement
d'être sujet à l'ordre du jour notamment
la présidente de la commission des lois
et elle brode pie v absolument vous fait
travailler avec eux pour que cette
proposition est une seconde vie si je
puis dire mais c'est ce que je fais
depuis des semaines et des semaines
notamment avec jean louis jean louis
touraine et il ya un groupe privé nous
travaillons ensemble avec je vous dis
des députés de tous les bords politiques
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le président du
groupe la république en marche doit
acter la position des démarcheurs qui
s'est exprimé on compte peu plus
clairement et il ya un mode olivier
verrons qui est passée un peu inaperçue
dans le débat il a dit non pas la
tribune mais après quand il a vu que moi
il à mesurer l'intensité du soutien des
marcheurs il a dit les obstructions
d'aujourd'hui sont souvent les les
adoptions de demain mais justement est
ce que le gouvernement ne tient pas une
sorte de double discours parce qu'on a
entendu beaucoup de ministres même le
président de la république qui sont
favorables à titre personnel toujours à
titre personnel à une aide active à
mourir
et puis après on voit bien que le sujet
il est très sensible on est dans une
période politique voilà un an de la
présidentielle et c est que ils veulent
pas s'en occuper pour l'instant emmanuel
macron a dit je veux choisir ma fin de
vie donc moi je souhaite que le chef de
l'état puisse
permettre aux autres français de pouvoir
aussi choisir la leur leur fin de vie
est ce que le parlement peut passer en
force sur ce sujet si le gouvernement si
le texte revient si votre texte via un
texte de la majorité elle rennes mais
que le gouvernement consent une
opposition nous allons voir ce que le
parlement
cette alliance transpartisane dont vous
targuer d'avoir vous est interdit
d'avoir construit peut faire aboutir ce
texte leur montrer sincèrement très
sincèrement lire je n'ai pas senti
d'hostilité du gouvernement olivier vers
ans en est remis à la sagesse de
l'assemblée
adrien taquet qui ensuite a siégé et
bien n'est pas rentré dans le piège du
dialogue
j'allais dire que voulait construire les
bloqueurs pour faire durer le temps et
empêcher le vote de l'article 1
donc il ya pas eu d'hostilité du
gouvernement très clairement au cours de
ce débat
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont acté que
leur majorité était favorable ce texte
et c'est pour ça que j'ai bon espoir que
le président du groupe la république en
marche et le gouvernement dans lequel il
y à un certain nombre de ministres qui
quand il était député avait soutenu
l'aide active à mourir
et bien c'est à dire qu'ils entendront
si on va un petit peu sur le fond à qui
s'adresse le texte est ce que pour vous
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de ten alesi
qui sont illégales en france et qui sont
pratiquées tout de même
alors merci de me donner l'occasion de
tordre le cou à tous les bobards l'effet
que news que l'on a pu entendre jusqu'à
entendre qu'on ne t'a nasier les enfants
autistes en belgique personnalités
éminentes qui qui a osé dire ça donc ce
texte il s'adresse aux personnes
majeures majeure et ce droit est
potentiellement accessibles aux malades
atteints d'une maladie incurable
alors quand on dire on vous allez tuer
les dépressifs la dépression n'est pas
une maladie incurable bien redresser ce
que vous d'une maladie incurable en
phase en phase avancée ou terminale
phase avancée ou terminale et générant
des souffrances inapaisables donc vous
voyez qu'il ya un cadre très précis et
que cette fois elles protègent elles
protègent le malade bien évidemment
parfois d'euthanasie qui sont pratiqués
dans la clandestinité et dont on ne sait
rien c'est souvent par humanité et le
médecin se retrouvent dans des
situations d'ailleurs intenable et cette
loi protège aussi le médecin en assurant
sa conscience par la clause de
conscience mais aussi en permettant de
faire cet acte qui lui est demandée par
le malade dans le cadre de la loi
donc c'est pour ces pour empêcher ces
états d'asie clandestine ans en france
que vous voulez aussi faire à passer
votre texte oui entre 2000 et 4000
euthanasies clandestines en france
chaque année il y à des françaises et
des français qui vont en belgique qui
vont en suisse madame d'un chat en a été
hélas j'allais dire député vous êtes
bien charles incarnation fils pour faire
un suicide assisté
alors que nous avions eu des débats et
j'avais eu des débats avec elle parce
qu'elle était hostile à l'époque à
l'euthanasie au suicide assisté donc on
voit bien que la loi actuelle montre
toutes ces insuffisances débats
suspendus donc que l'on suivra
prochainement mois passé la deuxième
partie de cette émission olivier falorni
le sénat qui poursuit l'examen du projet
de loi sur le séparatisme
[Musique]
la majorité sénatoriale de droite est en
train de durcir le projet de loi
comportant les principes de la
république voit le burqini mais aussi
l'interdiction des prières à
l'université ou encore suspension des
allocations pour absentéisme scolaire
les sénateurs ont aussi refusé le régime
d'autorisation prévues par le
gouvernement pour l'instruction à
domicile florilège des échanges avec
marion delpech le sénat a
considérablement durci le projet de loi
séparatisme l'amendement dit unef
initiée par les sénateurs les
républicains alexandra burke et aux
fantasmes et stéphane le rudulier a été
adopté jeudi à l'unanimité permettant de
dissoudre les associations faisant des
réunions non mixte aura 6 et adoption à
l'unanimité aussi de l'amendement
permettant au maire d'interdire les
drapeaux étrangers lors des mariages
une interdiction qui s'appliquerait si
le texte n'est pas retoquée par les
députés dans la salle des mariages et à
proximité de l'hôtel de ville
les sénateurs ont également voté
l'interdiction du port du voile par les
mineurs dans l'espace public ainsi que
l'interdiction des femmes voilées lors
des sorties scolaires
enfin le patron des sénateurs les
républicains n'est pas en reste avec
l'adoption de la proposition
d'interdiction des listes communautaires
aux élections
le sénat a adopté l'article samuel pâtit
sanctionnant la mise en danger d'autrui
par la diffusion d'informations
personnelles au cours d'une séance
marquée par un affrontement entre le
garde des sceaux et l'opposition qui
craint pour la liberté de la presse et
on est passé d'un système de
cautionnement à un système de cause de
contrôle a posteriori c'est à dire que
si il ya un acte diffamatoire alors qui
conque se sent diffamé peut attaquer la
presse concernant le renforcement de la
neutralité dans le monde du sport
l'amendement le plus emblématique vise à
interdire le port de signes religieux
ostensibles pour la participation aux
événements sportifs et aux compétitions
sur le volet de l'enseignement enfin
plusieurs dispositions ont été adoptées
l'interdiction des prières dans les
couloirs des universités la lutte contre
les actions de propagande perturbant la
tenue de conférences et l'interdiction
dans la loi des listes communautariste
aux élections étudiantes
enfin sur l'école en famille l'hémicycle
s'est opposé à l'autorisation préalable
souhaitée par le gouvernement après deux
semaines l'examen du texte par les
sénateurs le rapporteur stéphane
pieds-noirs s'inquiète du compromis
qu'il faudra trouver avec les députés
s'arrête évidemment compliqué et ensuite
à l'examen je compte vraiment sur la
sagesse des députés pour dire 'attendez
regarder entre les objectifs affichés
par le président de la république et la
réalité de ce texte tel que vous nous
l'avez livré au sénat il ya un grand
écart que nous avons essayé de combler
et si aucun accord n'est trouvé entre
sénateurs et députés l'assemblée
nationale statuera en dernier ressort
olivier falorni le sénat de droite a
donc largement chamboulé le texte on l'a
entendu la durci sur de très nombreux
volets sq pour vous le texte aujourd'hui
il est méconnaissable
méconnaissable nom et il ya des points
d'ailleurs sur lesquelles je me retrouve
impliqué il ya des points wii les
réunions non mx2 racisées je vous
l'auriez voter ça a été voté à
l'unanimité contraires à toutes les
valeurs que je porte vous savez moi je
galère de la république je mets
référence et michel et georges
clemenceau et michel crépeau donc des
grands républicains donc entendre parler
de réunions racisées en france donc
c'est inadmissible c'est inadmissible
inadmissible et donc je soutiens je
soutiens le choix des sénateurs
moi j'avais voté le texte à l'assemblée
nationale il me semblait être un texte
d'équilibré
après il ya un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont été faites savez moi je trouve
que donc on parle beaucoup de
l'instruction en famille mais je trouve
qu'on n'a pas mis assez l'accent sur les
écoles privées hors contrat
et moi j'avais demandé à ce qu'il y ait
autorisation préalable sur les écoles
privées hors contrat
une proposition de loi de françoise
gatel sur les écoles privées en contrat
qui a été adoptée il ya quelques années
pour vous c'est passé pas suffisant
aujourd'hui je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut une autorisation préalable puisque
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on peut ouvrir
une école et puis éventuellement il ya
un contrôle a posteriori je crois que
plus que l'instruction famille où il
peut y avoir éventuellement des
phénomènes de prosélytisme
mais je pense de façon à céret s'est
réduite en revanche un certain nombre
d'écoles
privé coranique pose de véritables
problèmes je parle bien hors contrat
vous dites écoles coraniques donc c'est
celle ci qui sont dans le viseur de ce
projet de loi pour vous ou est ce qu'il
y aurait d'autres
d'autres écoles d'autres religions c'est
vraiment les écoles vous savez il ya
effectivement des problèmes de
prosélytisme de l'islamisme radical mais
il ya des phénomènes sectaires des
phénomènes sectaires tout aussi
préoccupant et et parfois on oublie d'en
parler vous avez dit pour l'instruction
en famille c'est pas forcément le
problème principal il a monopolisé les
débats à l'assemblée comme au sénat
est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut quand
même la soumettre à un régime
d'autorisation parce que finalement
c'est surtout parce que les contrôles
sont insuffisants qui est qu'on est
obligé de faire cela bon le sénat
rappelons le a refusé un ce régime
d'autorisation tout à fait moi je pense
que par contre il n'y a pas assez de
contrôles de l'éducation nationale
il faut vraiment que vous savez moi je
suis enseignant et je suis très attaché
à l'école de la république et on voit
bien aussi et moi je le dis aux parents
de l'instruction en famille n'y a que je
respecte leur choix mais l'école l'école
c'est un lieu aussi de sociabilisation
et on voit bien aujourd'hui on ferme les
écoles et franchement moi j'ai deux
enfants ils sont ils en ont pleuré ils
en ont pleuré quand emmanuel macron et
pourtant parfois vous savez enfants ils
ont pas trop envisage je ne pensais
jamais voir mes enfants pleurer parce
qu'on leur dit vous ne pourrez plus
aller à l'école parce qu'ils ont besoin
de cette sociabilisation de voir leurs
profs de pouvoir échanger avec eux et je
pense que c'est un aspect qui ne faut
pas gommé après les familles font leur
choix mais en tout cas elles doivent
être strictement contrôlés pour vérifier
que et bien les conditions minimales
posée par l'éducation nationale soient
respectés alors les sénateurs ont aussi
rouvert le débat sur le
le voile dans l'espace public est ce que
pour vous le voile dans l'espace public
constitue un élément concret de
séparatisme ou pas moi je pense qu'il
faut réfléchir à ce à des nouvelles
formes d espace public laïque
par exemple dans une mairie est-ce que
les signes ostentatoires peuvent
s'afficher ou pas françois baroin avait
évoqué ce sujet lors de son audition en
commission
moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment
réfléchir à des espaces publics de
neutralité ce qui a évité cadre
religieux rien des dérives
je pense notamment à des crèches qui
n'ont rien à faire dans une mairie la
crèche elle doit être dans une église
pas dans une mairie donc il s'agit pas
de stigmatiser ou de pointer une
religion mais je pense que la mairie
doit être un lieu de neutralité et à mon
avis c'est une réflexion à mener sur le
court et moyen terme
voilà il le débat sur poursuit en tout
cas au sénat jusqu'à lundi pour conclure
cette émission va parler des élections
régionales vont elles pouvoir se tenir
en juin là est la question
[Musique]
certains dans l'opposition souhaiterait
reporter ces élections organisées en
pleine crise sanitaire en jouant
prochain mais le premier ministre l'a
redit le scrutin aura lieu coûte que
coûte on réécoute jean castex c'était le
1er avril à l'assemblée nationale nous
devrons également nous prononcer sur les
conditions d'organisation des élections
régionales et départementales prévues
les 13 et 20 juin prochains
ces élections ont déjà été reportés pour
cause de covin seules des raisons
sanitaires impérieuse de nature à
compromettre l'organisation de la
campagne ou du scrutin pourrait
justifier un nouveau report un débat
fondé sur l'article 51 de la
constitution sera réalisée au parlement
sur la base de l'ensemble de ces
éléments
olivier falorni questions très simples
faut-il maintenir ou reporter à nouveau
ces élections régionales et
départementales 1
je crois qu'on risque une bérézina
démocratique on l'a déjà connu pour les
municipales si on devait avoir des
élections régionales à 20 ou 30 % de
participation
ça risque d'être catastrophique natya en
tout cas moi ce qui me concerne un peu
c'est qu'on avait un an pour réfléchir à
des modalités différentes
on a vu enfin beaucoup de pays
continuent à voter
les etats unis sont pas toujours ma
référence en termes de démocratie mais
néanmoins par un système de vote par
correspondance
c'est vrai répondant situation il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été testées
en je suis contre le vote par
anticipation quoi parce que une campagne
elle va jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire
jusqu'au dernier jour
donc si vous voter par anticipation
quinze jours avant je crois que les
règles ne sont pas justes et si on fait
un étalement par exemple du vote sur
trois jours est ce que pour les mêmes
raisons vous estimez que ce n'est pas
juste parce que ça a été testé par
exemple aux pays bas où ils ont ouvert
le scrutin sur trois jours il ya eu des
très bons résultats en terme de
participation
ce que je trouve injuste c'est
par anticipation la campagne s'arrête et
effectivement on peut avoir au lieu
d'une journée de vote trois journées de
vote
effectivement ça me paraît souhaitable
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on va avoir en
plus des bureaux de vote où vous allez
avoir les régionales les départementales
les élections je souhaite bon courage au
maire pour organiser ça et je crains
qu'on ait du mal à trouver des
assesseurs alors obtenir les bouquets
sauriez-vous mesure vous dites il faut
éviter on risque une bérézina démocrate
et c'est ce que z qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour l'éviter éventuellement cette
bérézina et moratti quelles seraient les
mesures sanitaires que vous prendriez
pour que tout se passe au mieux
d'abord obligations fin proposition
vaccinale à tous les assesseurs à tous
les présidents de bureau de 20 ans je
crois que pour aujourd'hui ils doivent
être prioritaires cigs accepte d'être
assesseurs ça risque peut-être dans
motiver certains donc ça me paraît être
la condition première après on parlait
de bureaux de vote ouverts à l'extérieur
est-ce bien réaliste j'en doute mais le
problème c'est que nous n'avons pas
anticipé anticipé cette élection dont on
savait qu'elle se tiendrait alors elle
devait déjà se tenir en mars elles se
tiennent en juin honnêtement s'il ne se
tiennent pas en juin je ne vois pas
comment elle pourrait être reportée
donc il faut qu'on soit un an avant
l'élection présidentielle
donc alors on est coincé donc est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que vous nous dites ce
que vous dites on n'a pas forcément les
conditions pouvoir les faire
correctement en juin mais on passera à
voir dans la possibilité que ça tienne
forcément avant la présidentielle qui
était prêt à écouter dans ces cas là il
faut prolonger le mandat au delà de
l'élection présidentielle écoutez tout
cas moi c'est un regret un prix que je
ne vous dis pas ça avec plaisir reporter
une élection jeudi ronceray je pense un
des rares pays à reporter une élection
enfin je n'ai pas de souvenir de cas
depuis le début de la crise du coc vide
où on a dit on arrête les élections mais
du coup et pour la présidentielle
puisque si on n'a pas résolu tous ses
problèmes pour les régionales et
départementales il faut donc les
résoudre pour la présidentielle ce
serait à moi une catastrophe de devoir
les arrêter et bien justement qu'on
anticipe et concret les règles de
facilitation des procurations de
de permettre d'avoir au moins deux
procurations et de pas passer des heures
dans un bureau de police pour les avoir
et qu'on réfléchisse à la vote par
correspondance
merci ce sera donc le mot de la fin
merci olivier falorni d'avoir été sur ce
plateau pour nous parler de votre
proposition de loi et commenter
l'actualité
c'est la fin de cette émission très
bonne suite de programmes ciao
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'une école mythique
une école connu de tous et qui alimente
les fantasmes l'école nationale
d'administration a formé quatre
présidents de la république
neuf premiers ministres des dizaines de
ministres et grands patrons
elle est devenue synonyme de pouvoir
pourtant au départ l'école créée au
sortir de la seconde guerre mondiale
n'était pas fait pour ça c'était quoi
c'était l'idéal d'excellence au profit
de la république
mais au fil du temps les énarques
incarne un peu plus ses élites rendu
responsable de tout il faudra toujours
qu'elle est fonctionnaire qui assument
leur tâche aura toujours qu'il y ait des
gens plutôt bien formés qui prennent des
décisions je suis opposé la suppression
de l'ena ça reste une école d'excellence
elle est devenue une école élitiste et
donc on peut corriger cet élitisme et la
cour comptons de m demain à 21h sur
public sénat
mais ça y est bon mais balle à livrer
parce qu'il tâte ainsi en rapide ça
comme chaque année en avril
la saison de la fraise bat son plein à
carpentras philippe bond exploite quatre
hectares de serres malgré la crise
sanitaire ses carnets de commandes sont
bien remplis
on démarre la saison sur les chapeaux de
roue là on est en plein de production
depuis depuis dix jours quoi là on est
entre 3 et 4 tonnes par jour et on va
monter crescendo northampton quoi mais
pour tenir cette cadence
il faut des bras philippe bond dépend en
grande partie des travailleurs tunisiens
marocains ou espagnoles pour assurer sa
récolte alors quand l'union européenne a
fermé ses frontières aux voyageurs en
provenance du maroc et de tunisie à
cause du coc vide
s'il dit bon à redouter une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre on ça a été la forme
générale quoi ça a été la forme en
général parce que on allait attaquer la
saison et on feront se demander comment
on allait faire pour remercier nos
fruits poids mais les cultivateurs se
sont organisés en coopération avec
l'état une dérogation autorise la venue
des saisonniers marocains et tunisiens
la filière affrète elle-même d avion
pour les transporter depuis le maghreb à
la charge de l'employeur un protocole
sanitaire a été mis sur pied avec la rs
et salariés donc sont testés 72 heures
avant le départ de tunisie ou du maroc
ils sont testés à l'arrivée à marseille
et ils sont testés sept jours après leur
arrivée pour pouvoir entrer sur
l'exploitation koala et même sous la
serre il faut respecter les gestes
barrière travaillant sans merci mais on
fait attention aux liens sont au moins
une est le personnel en place assise
obligatoire sinon on ne sait jamais
vingt-quatre salariés ont commencé le
travail
philippe on en attend encore cinq autres
sur le prochain avion de tunisie
pour hassan brahim qui vient chaque
année depuis 18 ans cette solution est
un soulagement
c'est ce qu'à un moment vous avez eu
peur de ne pas pouvoir venir ne pas
pouvoir faire la saison
oui ce sont déjà cet avion qui ont été
affrétés par les producteurs de fraises
du vaucluse ce qui a permis de faire
venir
environ 800 travailleurs du maroc et de
tunisie
mais cette opération a un coût pour les
exploitants 400 euros par travailleur
en tout cela représente 600 mille euros
pour l'ensemble des producteurs de
fraises du département
[Musique]